in the video where we introduced the
alternating series test we in fact used
the series we use the infinite series
from n equals 1 to infinity of negative
1 to the n plus 1
over n we use we use this as our example
to apply the alternating series test and
we prove that this thing right over here
converges so this series which is one
which is
one
minus one half plus one-third minus
one-fourth and it just keeps going on
and on and on forever we use the
alternating series test in that video to
prove that it converges so this thing
converges
so this converges
converges by
alternating series test
by alternating
alternating
series
alternating let me my that looks a
little bit messy alternating
series test and if you want to review
that go watch the video on the
alternating series test
now let's take a little bit about what
happens if we were to take the absolute
value of each of these terms so if you
were to take the absolute value of each
of these terms so if you take the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of the
absolute value of negative 1
to the n plus 1
over n
well what is this going to be equal to
well this numerator is either going to
be 1 or negative 1 the absolute value of
that's always going to be 1 so it's
going to be that over and n is always
positive we're going from 1 to infinity
so it's just going to be equal to
the sum
it's going to be equal to the sum from n
equals 1 to infinity of 1 over n and
this is just the famous harmonic series
and there's this video that we have and
you should look it up on khan academy if
you don't believe me on the famous proof
that the harmonic series diverges so the
harmonic series is one plus one-half
plus one-third this thing right over
here this thing right over here di
diverges
and so when you see a series that
converges but if you were to take the
absolute value of each of its terms and
then that diverges we say that this
series converges conditionally
converges you can say it converges but
you could also say it converges
conditionally
and the condition is i guess you could
say that we're not taking the absolute
value of each of the terms
and the uh if it if something converges
when you take the absolute values well
then you say it converges absolutely and
so let's look at an example of that
if i were to take
this series
let's do a geometric series that might
be fun
actually i'm using these colors too much
let me use another color
let's say
let's take
the sum from n equals 1 to infinity of
negative one-half
to
the n
plus one power
we know this is a geometric series where
the absolute value of our common ratio
is less than one we know that this
converges
we know that this converges
and if we were to take the absolute
value of each of these terms so if you
were to take the sum let me do that in a
different color just to
mix things up a little bit
if you were to take
the absolute value of each of these
terms so the absolute value of
negative one-half
absolute value of negative one-half
to the
n plus one power this is going to be the
same thing as the sum
from
n equals one to infinity
of
one-half
to the n plus one and here once again
the the common ratio the absolute value
of the common ratio is less than one and
we studied this when we looked at
geometric series this also converges
this also converges so we took the
absolute value of the terms it still
converged so for this one we can say
that this converges
absolutely
absolutely so we've talked a lot already
about convergence or divergence and
that's all been good and what we're
doing in this video is we're introducing
a nuance or flavors of convergence so
you can converge but it might be
interesting to say well do we conver
would it still converge if we took the
absolute value of the terms if it won't
if you converge but it doesn't converge
when you take the absolute value of the
terms then you say it converges
conditionally
if it converges and it still converges
when you take the absolute value of the
terms then we say it converges
absolutely because even if you take the
absolute value of the terms it converges
hopefully
you find that interesting